The light of the sun
it takes 8 minutes to reach your eyes
Inside
all atoms form our mind
But yes
You think that science is not made for you
or that is not "woe"
Our formula will prove to you
Be careful and you will see how
We are about to spread a bit of science
The evolution was created by the brain, the heart, the spinal cord
And also the eyes
medicine created vaccines and technologies
They keep you alive
Every time you eat, read, chat
or do you make a selfie all smiling
No, science does not go out of fashion
Science never goes out of style
You love these applications for the iPhone that help you to bind
But they were the "crakcs" of science
those who first imagined them
With our dressing gowns and glasses
you will have knowledge set
Science never goes out of style
I say from the heart, take it seriously
People are "sexy" when he shows he's smart
Unlike all modes
science is logical and it is not over
Listen, I heard that
you went out to make a shot
and you're afraid of the "nerds"
Look, this is a spiked, do you know why?
Soon they will make innovations that will change our lives
and they will be famous forever.
The evolution was created by the brain, the heart, the spinal cord
And also the eyes
medicine created vaccines and technologies
They keep you alive
Every time you eat, read, chat
Or do you become a "selfie" all smiling
No, science does not go out of fashion
Science never goes out of style
You love these applications for the iPhone that help you to bind
But they were the "crakcs" of science who
they first imagined
With our dressing gowns and glasses
you will have knowledge set
Science never goes out of style
so do not be silly
So alone, do not be silly
Yes, do not be silly
Do not be a ***** XIMPLE
PASSAT OF FASHION